[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
réunis dans la capitale polonaise des
délégations venues des quatre coins du
monde ont commémoré l'un des drames les
plus poignants de la dernière guerre le
soulèvement et l'anéantissement en avril
1943 du ghetto de Varsovie dès 1940 les
chefs nazis avaient isolé à l'intérieur
d'un mur de 16 km 400
000 Juifs
dans ce quartier clos c'était condamné
toute une population à une vie
impossible 100 000 périr d'épidémie et
de famille
[Musique]
ce n'était pas assez
alors commencèrent ces impardonnables
qu'on voit vers les camps
d'extermination la solution finale était
en marche
[Musique]
et puis au printemps 1943 les 60000
Juifs encore au ghetto par la seule
vertu de l'espérance se soulevait décidé
à vendre cherment leur vie ce fut
l'anéantissement total maison par maison
il y a de cela 20 ans
se recueillir à Varsovie non pas oublié
[Musique]
le général de Gaulle a entrepris son 18e
voyage à travers la province française
et il rendait visites ce jour-là à Sedan
il devait se rendre ensuite à Mézières
et à Charleville en reprenant contact
avec la foule provinciale le général de
Gaulle a été touché par la chaleur de
l'accueil que lui avait réservé les
populations
dans ces allocutions le président de la
République a rappelé les lignes
directrices qui inspirent l'action du
gouvernement stabilité politique
évolution sociale construction de
l'Europe
[Applaudissements]
ajouter qu'un armement moderne est une
nécessité pour la garantie de
l'indépendance du pays
partout la foule a manifesté son
attachement au chef de l'État par ses
acclamations
dans le ciel de Courchevel une quinzaine
de concurrents participent au premier
critérium des parachutistes skieur
après un saut en chute libre il s'agit
de se poser le plus près possible d'un
point de repère tracé dans la neige à
plus de 2000 mètres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en dépit de l'altitude la moyenne de
précision des 10 premiers sera de 5 m 17
ce qui est remarquable le vainqueur
Claude trèfle pose les pieds à 50 cm du
coin idéal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette épreuve de précision au bout des
suspentes se doublent à l'arrivée d'un
concours de descente ski au pied car
c'est parachutistes sont également des
skieurs confirmés un jeu certes mais
aussi une expérience grâce à la rapidité
de leur intervention et à la précision
de leur seau ce sont des perspectives
insoupçonnées ouvertes au secours en
haute montagne par ses futurs
Saint-Bernard du ciel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas d'émotion en cours d'ennemis final
de la Coupe de France de football la
logique est respectée au grand désespoir
des amateurs de sensations fortes
à Marseille la belle aventure des
Toulonnais maillot clair c'est terminé
par un échec devant les Lyonnais échec
sévère par trois butins qui doit
beaucoup à la malchance
on parle des Princes devant Monaco
l'équipe numéro un du football français
les Rémoises noires eux aussi ont
invoqué la malchance mais à tort ils
sont tombés sur plus fort que
race pourtant marque le premier but par
hackésby
alors commence le match poursuite Monaco
- égalise Reims reprend l'avantage
Monaco égalise encore voilà qui est fait
c'est finalement Monaco qui a le dernier
mot trois à deux Monaco et Lyon joueront
la finale de la Coupe de France
[Musique]
on l'appelle entre initier le Père
Tranquille du rock le Tino Rossi du
rythme dans sa gentilhommière de
Chevreuse Richard Anthony qui avait déjà
vendu l'an dernier 3 millions de disques
et l'un de ceux que la fortune a comblé
à l'âge 25 ans où l'on est généralement
riche que d'espérance
comment il suffit de le suivre un soir à
Paris ou à Bordeaux à Courbevoie ou à la
salle des fêtes de Melun
kerque à Biarritz de Brest à Strasbourg
5 millions de ceux qui ont entre 13 et
19 ans ont ainsi adopté des vedettes
bien à eux apôtre de leur musique le
rock et le twist
[Applaudissements]
es de cinéma n'ont qu'à bien se tenir
ce que l'exemple des Johnny des Richards
ou des Sylvie dont la réussite est
inscrite dans les microsillants ne
manque pas de provoquer l'émulation
témoin les vendredis du golf de Rouault
ce temple ce saint des saints du twist
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le vendredi c'est le jour où l'on vient
présenter à ses pères la petite
formation qu'on a monté entre copains
avec l'espoir de faire à son tour un
disque à plusieurs l'audace c'est plus
facile
[Musique]
on compte aujourd'hui 3000 formations de
ce type en France combien demain
[Musique]
fait significatif le commerce des
guitares est en plein essor on en a
vendu en un an autant qu'il s'est vendu
de voiture la guitare entendait celle
qui fait du bruit la guitare électrique
[Musique]
et on l'a choisi comme sa cravate devant
une glace
[Musique]
après quoi on cherche des partenaires il
existe pour cela tout un système
d'affichage sans oublier les petites
annonces dans les revues spécialisées
qui permettent de pressentir le
guitariste blond et le batteur châtain
de ses rêves
on s'entraîne et si l'on a de la chance
on trouve un studio d'enregistrement
dans le 16e à Paris par exemple
[Musique]
sinon avec les moyens du bord on
enregistre quand même sur place à
l'atelier ou au garage
[Musique]
être apprécié par ses copains c'est bien
mais évidemment l'important le but est
d'enregistrer au moins une bande
magnétique que l'on pourra toujours
envoyer par la poste à une maison
d'édition car ainsi vont les choses
aujourd'hui quand quelques semaines une
vedette fenêtre par la grâce du micro
sillon
[Musique]